RUN HE HAS HAD HERE OVER THE
LAST TWO WEEKS.
>> Ann: THE BENCH HAS REALLY
STEPPED UP IN THE SECOND HALF.
>> KEVIN: D.A. CONTESTING THE
SHOT FROM D ROSE, AND TAJ GIBSON
JUST THROWING AN ELBOW INTO THE
BACK OF CHRIS PAUL.
>> Ann: HE'S TALKING TO THEM
TOO, THEY KNOW EACH OTHER FROM
U.S.A. BASKETBALL.
CHRIS PAUL JUST TURNED 36, AND
TAJ GIBSON IS 35.
>> KEVIN: WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST
TIME THE SUNS AND KNICKS HAVE
MIXED IT UP.
>> Ann: MONTY WILLIAMS PULLING
HIM AWAY.
GIBSON COMES DOWN ON PAUL AND
THEN THROWS AN ELBOW INTO HIM.
>> KEVIN: THAT WILL BE VIEWED
AND -- IT LOOKED LIKE GIBSON WAS
ALMOST UPSET THAT PAUL HAD BOXED
HIM OUT FOR THE REBOUND.
LOOK AT IT HERE.
>> Referee: POSSIBLE FLAGRANT
FOUL.
>> Ann: GIBSON THROWS THAT
SHOULDER INTO CHRIS PAUL, CHRIS
PAUL DOES A GREAT JOB, ALWAYS
WALKS AWAY FROM ANY KIND OF
CONFRONTATION, BUT TELLING HIM,
YOU THREW AN ELBOW AT ME.
AGAIN, YOUR EMOTIONS IN THE HEAT
OF THE MOMENT WHEN